[Música]
economía en directo América de France 24
Daniela Blandón con nosotros en el
estudio Daniela vamos a hablar de una
noticia muy importante porque este lunes
entra en vigencia un embargo occidental
al petróleo ruso Hola Raúl pues esta es
una medida que ya está aprobada por la
Unión Europea y que originalmente nació
en el grupo de los siete países más
poderosos del mundo entra entonces en
vigor el lunes cinco de diciembre como
parte de un boicot que quiere hacer
occidente al petróleo ruso a partir de
esa fecha el bloque de comunitario
dejará de comprar crudo ruso entregado
por mar lo que se cree que llegaría a
impactar hasta el 90% de las
importaciones que hoy hacen desde ese
país exoviético la Unión Europea esta
medida desde luego excluyó las entregas
por oleoducto porque esa fue una de las
condiciones que puso un Hungría que no
tiene salida al mar y que depende en
parte del hidrocarburo ruso no solamente
del petróleo también del gas natural
Dani le preguntó el objetivo de esta
medida el objetivo de esta medida y de
todas las sanciones que ha impuesto
occidente desde que inició la Guerra en
Ucrania es ahogar las finanzas del
kremlin a través de la reducción de los
ingresos de Rusia por la venta que hace
de petróleo al resto del mundo y es que
se cree que los ingresos del kremlin por
el comercio de petróleo están en su
nivel más bajo desde principios de
dinero sin embargo eso no quita que la
guerra sí haya favorecido a Rusia que es
el segundo mayor productor del mundo
occidente cree que Vladimir Putin ha
podido financiar esta invasión a Ucrania
porque producir un barril de petróleo le
cuesta entre 30 y 40 dólares por barril
como lo vemos en este gráfico Este es el
costo de producción el que llamamos
costo de producción sin embargo el punto
de equilibrio fiscal que es en donde las
finanzas están en una buena salud está
entre 60 y 70 dólares y recordemos que
el
del petróleo ha estado inclusive ha
pasado los 110 dólares por barril al
principio de la guerra y quién le compra
a Rusia Entonces si no es occidente
bueno primero hay que decir que Rusia
produce el 10% de petróleo mundial o
mejor lo entrega lo exporta la idea de
las sanciones de la Unión Europea es de
tener casi todas las entregas de crudo
por vía marítima que hace Rusia a los
miembros del bloque comunitario el
kremlin entonces puede tener
dificultades para encontrar compradores
para todo ese millón más de un millón de
barriles diarios que envía a Europa que
anteriormente era su mayor cliente sin
embargo probablemente redirigirá la
mayoría de ellos al tiempo que Europa se
dispone a encontrar nuevos proveedores
en el mercado global y si no es Europa
quién para responderle su pregunta un
informe de la agencia especializada
bloomberg señala que dos tercios del
crudo cargado en los puertos rusos se
dirige en este momento a Asia
principalmente a China a India Turquía
estos tres países se han convertido en
los mayores compradores de los barriles
rusos desplazados por Europa y una parte
menor va a sri lanka y emiratos árabes
Unidos por ejemplo se estima que estas
naciones compran unos dos coma cuatro
millones de barriles por día y además lo
hacen a un precio más favorable porque
Rusia se los está vendiendo más baratos
y si antes de la guerra de Rusia este
país les proveía dos quintas partes de
su petróleo a todos estos países
asiáticos hoy lo reciben dos terceras
partes O sea que ha incrementado
significativamente Bueno y cómo
afectaría Esto entonces a los ciudadanos
europeos porque finalmente son los que
pagan los altos precios de pues
absolutamente todo no Empezando por la
energía el sobre todo de cara al
invierno Así es Raúl esta medida Podría
tener un efecto incierto primero que
todo en el precio del petróleo Porque si
bien habrá pérdida de suministro también
hay temores sobre una menor demanda en
una economía global que está en plena
desaceleración además es posible también
que el mayor impacto del embargo de la
Unión Europea no llegue este lunes
cuando el continente encuentra nuevos
proveedores y los barriles rusos se han
desviados sino el 5 de febrero por qué
Porque en esa fecha entra en vigor la
prohibición adicional sobre los
productos de refinería hechos de
petróleo Como por ejemplo El combustible
diesel ahora Europa todavía tiene muchos
vehículos que funcionan con este
combustible que también se usan los
camiones que llevan una amplia gama de
bienes a los consumidores adicionalmente
para hacer funcionar la maquinaria
agrícola también se utiliza del diesel
por lo que todos estos costos más altos
a partir de febrero se van a distribuir
en toda la economía seguramente Dani
como siempre Gracias por toda la
información económica más la próxima
semana